hey man it's me kevin smith coming to
you to talk about peacemaker the new
show on hbo max by james gunn oh my god
um
i can't
give a show higher praise than this yes
it is the cursing superhero show which
rocks but it's so much
more gunn takes a character from suicide
squad
uh played by john cena who was funny in
the movie um he's got that rap about you
know he'd eat uh if this beach was full
of dicks i'd eat them all for you know
for peace
um
he proved very deft with the material he
looks like an action figure i mean i
hate to bring it down to the aesthetics
but like my god he literally looks like
like a dc character and so you squeeze
him into that peacemaker outfit
pitch perfect looks like he belongs on a
blister card for heaven six
um the character itself
came from charlton
comics back in the day the same people
who gave us
um the uh the question
um captain adam in fact
when alan moore uh dc comics picked up
the charlton characters
alan moore came up with a pitch for the
characters where he's like i'm gonna
tell a story about like you know
deconstructing them as heroes and
and how like life is different in the
present and dc was like ah we just
picked up these characters maybe we want
to use them for other things can you
make your own characters and then he
rewrote it as the watchman
so peacemaker
was
was the model
for the comedian from the watchmen so
this character's been around for a
red-hot
minute he's new to some people because
he's new in the dc movies
um and not a character that most people
ever thought to use using them in
suicide squad was brilliant because he
is a guy who you could portray as like
he'll stop at nothing he'll kill
everyone just for peace he's telling a
story in the genre that hasn't been told
before telling a grown ass story using
like action figures for heaven six would
have been so easy for him to smash smash
them into each other and just have him
curse at each other but instead he's
telling a story with action figures with
toys that have a real human soul
and heart to him so
uh as we saw in suicide squad
peacemaker was uh [ __ ] up pretty badly
by the end of the movie like you thought
he was dead but then in the ps they were
like buffalo graham did he's going to
work and they were setting up the series
which uh i guess james
came to them with before they were he
was done
working on the movie
so he knew he could keep the story going
um you know peacemaker kills rick flagg
which is like such a piece of [ __ ] move
rick flagg was about to expose you know
project starfish and whatnot and
peacemaker kills him because he says
like that's his mission amanda waller
says you know don't let the information
get out
and as rick flagg is dying he's his
peacemaker what a joke and
this whole series is about
you know chris the peacemaker himself
christopher smith no relation whatsoever
um
becoming
the person that
he was
that he thought he was uh
he was kind of a joke um and
he's gonna
learn to live with that or change that
we're gonna just see an arc a human arc
with a doll kids with an action figure
um
basically
uh gunn gets to fire
his fully loaded gun if he will
um at
family relationships
look you can have the best writer in the
world don't matter if you don't have
performers who can't pull off the
material and oh my god he's got a great
cast here uh number one
john's wonderful in the in the lead role
uh a harcourt played by jennifer holland
absolutely great
character wonderful foil
tough as nails
having uh the great steve agee
on a show on a regular basis it was
delightful to see him in suicide squad
seeing him you know on a weekly basis in
peacemaker
gets to show off his chops his acting
job he's a funny guy but he also gets to
show off his dramatic chops as well and
his his judo chops as well literally uh
shakuti iwuji i hope i'm getting that
right i'm playing mern
um who
keep an eye on murder in episode four
um
wonderful supporting cast
of of peacemaker's team
then there's peacemaker's best friend
uh freddy stroma is playing adrian chase
vigilante who in comics
has a very tragic story particularly
ending um in in this he's an absolute
delight and the two of them together
john and freddie
bounce off each other incredibly well
really legit funny dialogue that they're
doing danielle brooks playing leota the
other beating
heart of this show uh that's right kind
of there with with peacemaker feels like
it's their story together and they have
this
sweet unlikely
relationship that both actors are
pulling off expertly and not lee as as
judo master is wonderful and hysterical
um that watching him square off against
peacemakers just visually
pleasing uh but also like a fun
character always eating chips i identify
with that guy right away
um so
crazy great
cass even got you know a little bit of
amanda waller in there
on the down low that was pretty [ __ ]
sweet too
um i can't wait to see where it goes in
the future man i hope they get another
sea i hope they get many seasons because
if you're if you could tell this story
with these characters in season one
sky's the limit man so
he's telling a a story of how do you
deal with
relatives and or in this situation
parents
who are larger than life and whose views
are different than yours and
but your blood and can you love somebody
that that's that big a piece of [ __ ]
like
this deep cut stuff kids in a show that
spun off of suicide squad which was a
movie that like again something i love
had a giant starfish in it
so it's gruesome like you know the
effects are gory
the fights are fun
and legit
the violence is uh like cartoonish
mayhem
um
it doesn't shy away
from being exactly what it is like i'm
shocked at how much they get away with
on the show like there's a lot of very
non-pc stuff going on in the show but in
the context
it works absolutely perfectly if
anything it shows you what's
capable what kind of storytelling is
capable
um you know years ago if you were going
to make this as a movie people be like
who's this for and they wouldn't make it
thankfully
the folks at hbo max are like you know
who's going to like this people like
like quality storytelling let's let's
make it and let people find out about it
and i hope people find out about it man
they're how can they not james gunn
making the dc universe
you know a place that you don't want to
see go
and doing it with
toys that zach put in motion like
it's a beautiful thing man um in a world
where
you know you don't get
uh snyder verse
this is pretty damn close he's still
playing in it but yet making it his own
uniquely his own james has always been a
wonderful writer and uh it shows
in peacemaker
i was lucky enough to you know i watched
the first three when they dropped like
everybody else and then i got
to watch the fourth episode
early
so you know
sometimes i pull strings sometimes i use
what i've put together in this life from
[ __ ] scratch kids and yes i call in
favors and be like can i see a [ __ ]
thing early and nine and a half times
out of ten they don't get back to me but
this time
they were like yeah you can watch
episode four early even better
they gave us a clip preview
of episode four which we're going to
show you right now this is what's going
to happen in the episode that's dropping
this week tomorrow i believe so let's
take a look right now a sneak preview
of peacemaker episode four check it out
listen i've been meaning to thank you
for allowing me to be tortured last
night
you're welcome
you know i was for a minute i was i was
kind of po like you didn't care about
the fact that i was in
you know agonizing pain
okay yeah but then i realized you were
you were just supporting me and helping
me to become the best me that i could be
someone who doesn't spill the beans
while being electrocuted and having half
his toe cut off you seem to be walking
okay well i'll probably never walk as
good again
but it's worth it you know for being a
more evolved human being so
thank you
i've never had a friend quite like you
what it just seems like under the
surface you're kind of angry about it
i'm not seems like you're well i'm not
at all dude okay the way you said dude
right there what seems miffed so like i
always say you know what if anything you
should be grateful because you would
feel really guilty if i gave that guy
information because you were too much of
a candy ass to take a little torture oh
yeah i would have been real guilty you
see that that right there was angry no
it wasn't it was normal i was i was
agreeing with you
come on man
like
that is my kind of speed like i love
that that's my vibe right there oh my
god that's some pitch perfect writing as
far as i'm concerned that's writing
ladies and gentlemen if
if we i wish we had james gunn here
right now so i could just tell him how
damn talented he is um but like i said i
know people
so
straight from atlanta ladies and
gentlemen from the set of another movie
i give you the great the loaded but not
in a liquor way ah james gunn excellent
to speak to you sir how are you i'm good
i'm really good you know it's been a an
insane week for me with uh between
shooting and trying to release the show
and everything else so but i feel good
uh the incredible first world problems
that you enjoy
of uh making a massive wonderful new
mill a movie while releasing
a massive new wonderful tv show based on
a masterful wonderful movie a massive
wonderful movie that you just did
last year you're busy cat my friend and
rightfully very busy yeah let's talk
about where peacemaker comes from i
absolutely love the show when i first uh
saw the trailer when i first heard it
was going to spin off i was like oh that
makes sense he's cool
fun character you can go places with it
uh when i saw the trailer i was like oh
i can't wait superheroes cursing like i
was almost cursing myself for like why
didn't i do this
um
then i saw the show
and once again what what you do insanely
well is give us the populist
entertainment that puts us in the seat
and then you sneak
a wonderful human story with a soul and
emotion under it and i did not suspect
that that's what we were going to be
having with peacemaker i thought it
would just be a fun romp and it remains
a fun romp but you are having your cake
and eating it too at the same time with
the story man uh it is
next level work you're always a
fantastic writer and a clever one at the
very least
but this there's something coming out in
this work man that like
it seems a little bit deeper and closer
to home than we've even seen before
where's it coming from
well i mean i think it was a couple of
things i think number one i just really
wanted to work with john
but number two a lot of the stuff i've
dealt with is are sort of these fables
like guardians is a fable about
childhood trauma that takes place in
outer space
it's very emotional but it's also it's
an outer space we don't have to deal
with real humans uh but peacemaker has a
little bit to do a little bit more to do
with you know society today what's going
on in our world what are the kind of
people that are you know in our world
and so
dealing with that social stuff a little
bit more i felt like peacemaker was a
character who gave me an opportunity to
deal with that and giving me the
opportunity also to deal with the
character of leo da adebayo who's played
by daniel brooks and the fact that two
of them have this sort of
you know beautiful friendship that they
find because it's based
strictly on their love or their
like for each other as human beings and
um and i thought that that was an
interesting dynamic and maybe something
that we should talk a little bit more
about about how people with very very
different belief systems can actually
like each other and i have people in my
own life that are like that people who
you know believe very differently than i
do about politics about this about
whatever and and instead of being a
person that screams at people
thinking that that somehow is going to
change their mind um
you know can see somebody else's
humanity despite their different beliefs
that's what really is on display when
you watch the show um you know there's a
cartoony level of violence and fun
but it's got this incredibly human
uh heart and soul um
i as i watched
the first episode and then went straight
into the next three because the hbo max
dropped all the first three episodes at
once
uh my impression i got
or let me let me ask you
when you went into suicide squad were
you thinking
peacemaker series at all it occurs to me
as like you're working with an actor
who's so talented that you're like
this is a versatile action figure that i
could do a lot of things with he's fun
and he also knows how to play
heart and warmth and stuff like and plus
the character being larger than life you
know you get to play with the archetypes
of superheroes while playing with a
classic superhero not even one that you
had to create yourself so you can break
down
which was it chicken or the egg how did
we get to peacemaker uh the egg
i guess
that means it was it was definitely john
cena i mean it was
wanting to work with john again because
listen this was you know
the beginning of coven when i decided to
do this i was lonely john and i get
along extraordinarily well i thought
he'd be a fun guy to make a tv show with
i trust him with my life he's a truly
good
uh individual with a lot of integrity
but i also thought you know i saw
glimpses of what john was capable of in
uh peacemaker we talked a lot about who
this guy was where he came from how he
felt awkward when he's around everybody
else what his dad was like you know all
of these things we talked about with
with john and then i saw glimpses of
what john was able to do
emotionally or dramatically that we
didn't really get to deal with you know
when we see
the big moment in suicide squad without
giving a major spoiler away which
anybody these peacemakers gonna be
spoiled you know there's this this
humanity in john that he brings to it
and i wanted to deal with that i thought
that is a seed for a whole
you know a whole television series
really the um
you're handling the material with a
plumb
uh with somebody who clearly has not
just affection for the genre like i said
you could have delivered
you holding you know two dc action
figures smash them together cursing at
each other and that would have been
like a wonderful show to watch at least
for me right up my alley the fact that
you're making a show that like other
people can get into even if you're not
into the superhero genre oh thanks so
much man and it's like you know i think
one of the things is not thinking of the
villains as villains while i'm writing
although that's hard with auggie smith
but i just think of all these these
they're different opposing forces i mean
somebody brought up to me the other day
because i'm a big fan of annie chang and
lachlan monroe who play fitzgibbon and
song the the cops that are on the
trailer peacemaker and i said something
about them the other day and somebody
said yeah but they're kind of like
villains because they're after the
peacemaker and i'm like what and
somebody said it today about judo master
judo master is a villain on twitter and
i'm like he's a villain i'm like oh i
guess he is to me he's not i mean he's
got his reasons for doing things and you
know and and annie and you know i mean
sophie song and fitzgibbon especially
have their reasons for doing things so i
just think of them as all these opposing
forces that have different desires that
move against each other you know and for
the show itself i don't even really 100
think of it as i think of the superhero
costumes or just the gravy you know
because it really is about you know
you know my version of adrian chase my
version of christopher smith emilia
harcourt you know leo dada bio it's
about those people
and a couple of them happen to wear
these costumes which are kind of
ridiculous really vigilante looks kind
of cool a peacemaker you know he's got
he's got he's a little challenged in the
uh coolness department i can't tell you
how how beautiful i thought his
his sustaining rationale for like
there's not a dove of peace on the gun
man
like how important it was like the
the mythology he built for himself which
is like that's what makes it
okay to do these horrible things that's
some that's some beautiful writing let's
talk about for one of the last things is
uh and it's the thing that seems to have
captured the imagination of people who
haven't even perhaps watched the show
yet is your opening credit sequence you
defeating the skip button by putting
together
one of the most compelling opening
sequences to a tv show since laverne and
shirley for heaven's sake since we
watched them skip down to shamil shimazu
where'd you get the idea man where where
did did you know early on was it the
kind of self challenge
i mean one of the things that excited me
about doing the show is there's no rules
i mean there's no rules whatsoever they
were gonna let me do whatever uh
you know so i'm like i wanted a dance
sequence i did this i did a movie called
super and i have an animated dance
sequence at the beginning of that that
isn't so different from this version but
in this i had a budget and an ability to
do it live action so i wanted a way to
tell the first of all i did i wanted
people to be able to see the names at
the beginning and not skip over all
those you know you know fred raskin the
editor and greg you know
greg diario and greg featherman our
other editors and uh you know all the
people that work so hard on on the show
and not to be able to skip over their
names
but also to let people know don't don't
think you know what you're seeing don't
don't think this is you know another
r-rated superhero show don't think this
is just this don't think it's that
open your mind it can be anything and
there are no rules here let's just go
along for the ride and so that was what
i wanted to get across you know with uh
with the opening credits whole sequence
is is brilliant and fun to watch um but
for me the big moment is uh mern and
harcourt come out for some reason that's
the shot that i'm drawn to they are so
perfectly intense that's the best yep
yeah it's but the whole thing is
absolutely so good joy
jen has these great arms and she's uh
it's also she's an amazing dance so
she's the one person that uh carissa
barton who choreographed that bit uh she
she gave jen
a little bit more to do than some of the
other people because she's she's
actually able to dance you know it's
just john's a little bit more he's got
his you know simple things that he's
doing but it absolutely works and i'm
i'm so fascinated by
why it starts
when it starts like five beats in was
that you going like i know i'm going to
end the opening cold opening with the
opening chords of that song so i'm going
to leave myself straight
that's right yeah fantastic that's right
it's fun talking to you about this show
cause nobody mentions that sort of stuff
i love it it makes me so happy to see
him standing there for the first like
two seconds of music without moving and
at first i was like is that a creative
choice and i was like it has to be him
trying to like
figure out in advance and i love it the
other thing about the
when the ending did you
did you know you were gonna hold on them
for like three seconds so that you see
people being people
it is that is brilliance absolute
brilliance and bliss it's so human man
it make because first you're sitting
there going that's pretty [ __ ]
impressive but then when you see
everybody like
it
it
binds you those characters my favorite
thing about i like i like the olympics
and i like ice skating performances and
stuff but there's always that moment at
the end of the ice skating
where they're frozen yes
and sometimes they're they're happy
because they just kick the ass and other
times you know they're they're beating
the [ __ ] out of themselves because they
didn't do very well but they got to sit
there with that smile and the out of
breath and that little moment of
humanity it was one of my favorite
things in ice skating
i i can't wait to watch
uh the rest uh i can't wait to see it
more i it feels like
it's something that you could return to
again and again and again i hope i hope
this ain't a one and done thing because
yeah yeah we all want to do that so
we're we're all
john and me and the whole crew we're all
into it so this is the highest
compliment i could possibly pay it i
never watch it and go [ __ ] it should
have been me i watch it and go [ __ ] this
was made for me
like okay
it really feels like a show that like oh
my god like had i never made a thing in
life
this would be the show that i put
everything down for because that's the
show i'm putting everything down for now
it's pitch perfect man i'm absolutely
loving what you did so glad you do thank
you for doing it keep making that piece
keep guarding that galaxy my friend i
will go thank you man i'll talk to you
soon give it up for james gunn ladies
and gentlemen thank you for hanging out
as i sit here and gush
on peacemaker peacemaker watch it right
now
every thursday on hbo max a new episode
is dropping you can watch the first
three already and you could watch the
brand new one thursday episode four is
dropping episode five
my prediction
i shall love it
i've loved it so far and my god it's
only getting better peacemaker ladies
and gentlemen peace out
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask if anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith